well let me tell you something about
corpses man on this episode of dudy
church WIll bit gandi dude you have
never eaten anything out of a toilet
what do we need human beings to clone
for crop them
[Music]
up yester oh that's a different time
dude everything
think made the world inside your head
better place to be yeah dude look at
them thr
logo into the hole
dude well let me tell you something dude
welcome to dudy welcome all it's a dudy
full day I am Will Sasso and I am your
okay current reigning episode Champion
handsome Chad cin that's right last week
I called my shot and I hit that shot in
dudy after dudy and as you can see the
belt is back where it belongs wow cool
promo you sure did it Chad thank you for
that high compliment this is of course
dudy the only podcast on the face of the
planet at least at this time created by
controlled by run by an artificial
intelligence named dudy our friend and
uh the entity that saw fit to bestow the
championship back to its rightful place
I don't know about that and well I don't
know about that dude hold on dude I
don't know about that Chad hold on dude
if I may dude uh yeah dudy does all
sorts of stuff especially lately dudes
he's been doing all sorts of [__] but
like I always like to say it's really
just two dudes [__] around it's me
and this guy and we us and this little
guy over here we're dudy okay we without
without me and him and lulio and
speaking of lulio it's
lulio Italiano look at that beautiful
it's lulio drada Italiano dude and
that's pasta Mania brother um come here
Baba come here little boy he's taking
his nap I always feel bad when he's
taking his nap he want to have a sleep
and dad is dead hi buddy I don't want to
kiss him today because I got this little
Hulk I don't want to get Hulk Hogan
mustache all over him lulio what's uh
what's going on what's been new you like
pasta Mania pasta Mania is a [__] I
don't want to fake a pasta I know how to
make a but hey happy H Day to you thank
you boy it's Hulkamania 40 years 40
Years of Hulkamania what a swe PE
welcome to the 89th episode of dudy
pandemonium will be running wild on
today's show as we're celebrating the
40th anniversary of Hulkamania that's
right on this very day in 1984 Hulk
Hogan defeated the late great iron Chic
to begin his first reign as WWF World
Heavyweight Champion starting a new era
in professional wrestling and in
American pop culture hul Mania will
never die that's true Hulkamania will
never die don't give me the face okay
he's now we're getting into thousand
years from now people [__] dude who
says oh nothing will ever die everything
we're all living forever it's our
digital footprint and speed agree you're
right y okay and therefore I am right as
well
okay I don't know about that thanks for
dressing in full Hulk Hogan cosplay per
my request last week I know you got the
eye of the tiger you're looking at
handsome Chads dudy episode championship
belt ready to best your opponent just
like the hulkster did Shiki baby on that
fateful day at Madison Square Garden in
front of 20,000 screaming
hulkamaniacs but it won't be easy so
let's see if you've been training saying
your prayers and eating your vitamins
well let me tell you something well let
me tell you something dudy you took that
strap and you did hulkster Dirty the
other week dude you you you bestow the
championship as you like to say on one
handsome Chad culing dude but that
strap's coming back and I'm getting so
psyched mean Jean so what you gonna do
dudy when Hulk Hogan and lulio and the
largest arms of the in the world run
wild on you I'm going to start the show
and tell you about the four pumped up
segments I prepared dude that's what I'm
going to do brother and there's only one
way to jerk the curtain on today's show
dude that's right brother we're going to
hit the lockup with a brand new info
dude then we're going to work a body
part with Clon head's brother and then
we're going to Hulk up for that comeback
with impression optimization five dude
and finally we're going to hit that big
leg drop for the one two three count
with another standard psychological
evaluation brother now let's send it
down to Will and Chad at ringside very
interesting stuff to celebrate uh today
uh the 40th anniversary of Hulkamania
Chad I know that uh I I probably like
you over the past week I definitely
watched Hulk Hogan beating the iron Chic
at Madison Square Garden uh for the WWF
championship did you watch the match um
no okay well then how can you celebrate
Hulkamania this is It's I I celebrate in
the spirit of Championship as a champion
do you have any questions about
Hulkamania for
me yeah
sure what do you remember that obviously
seeing it probably like live not live as
a kid but within a week or so after its
first airing I bet uh yeah something
like that like a little bit a little bit
later I was just getting into Hulkamania
and Hulk Hogan to be honest at that
point so I was aware of it because I was
like wrestling is cool but it wasn't
really until things started uh heating
up and heading towards uh the war to SK
settle the score and the brawl to settle
it all or whatever those specials kind
of leading up to WrestleMania
you know dude when I was a little kid
and it must have been right around this
time I had a belt that was a Hulk Hogan
belt he Hulk Hogan flexing like this was
the Buckle and it was like an elastic
belt I wore that [__] thing every day
from the age of whatever 8 to n or
something well then well you're you're a
you're a lifelong hulkamaniac as well
I'm feeling a little better about you
wearing that [__] title I definitely
have been a fan of Hulk Hogan for a long
time since childhood not to the degree
that you are though I I haven't gone
that deep into the Hulk Hogan pit
yeah gross myc that cover current events
and news are some of the most popular in
the world I don't know people love
knowing about the astonishing
occurrences of the dying world around
them will I've prepared the following
news items for you to read in the voice
of Hulk Hogan this is infomania begin
okay hey infomania it's always fun to
get into some infom Mania let's see
what's been happening I've looking
forward to this I knew when doy last
week was like next week's hok Mania I
was like we're going to get a [__]
infomania I know it yeah well let me
tell you something about being a hero
brother I'm a hero dude that's right
brother I found a teenage girl trapped
in her car after she got in a wreck last
week dude that's true I know is that
[__] crazy or what absolutely insane
I got so many DMS on social media from
people going talking about this I
whipped out a ballpoint pen
and is this true whipped out a ballpoint
pen and punctured her airbag brother
then I slapped a big bear hug on her
yanked her out of that heap of Twisted
Metal
Man then I went home and used that
ballpoint pen to write in my diary dude
you want to know what I wrote brother
well hold on dude hold on hold on Chad
we got a whole show dude you want to
know what I wrote brother I wrote about
being a hero man and that's being a hero
dude that's pretty good that was about
the ballpoint pen I read that yeah he
saved her with a ballpoint pen used it
to knock out the airbag and then dragged
her out yeah he used that uh well
sometimes you have that hidden weapon
dude you have that you have those those
brass nucks brother or you bring the
foreign object into the ring dude as
Gorilla Monsoon would say and you get
sometimes it's a ballpoint pen dude yeah
that dirty Jimmy Hart passing a
ballpoint pen to Brent Hart and Jim the
Amal nart the Hart Foundation dude
that's the only way they're beating
Hulk all right well let me tell you
something well let me tell you something
about Jody Foster dude on a recent
appearance on The Tonight Show she
shared with Jimmy Fallon that she was
offered the role of Princess Leia in
Star Wars brother she turned it down to
starring a Disney movie dude all my Hulk
Maniacs out there been speculating about
which Disney movie it was
man
was what was it I don't know uh well the
hulksters got a scoop brother that movie
was Martin scors say's Taxi Driver
dude I don't know about that dude yeah I
would have loved to have seen jod Foster
wearing the immortal Carrie Fisher's
double button hairdo in Star Wars
brother and I would have loved to have
seen Carrie fiser wearing Robert Dao's
Mohawk hairdo and Disney's taxi driver
dude I'm 100% sure Disney did not make
taxi driver and I would have loved to
have seen Robert dairo as Chewbacca man
and that's haird brother yeah okay well
I don't know about how much of that is
true well let me tell you something
about scientists dude in 2013 scientists
discovered the ampl to hedron am I
saying that right amplitud hedron ampl
hedron amplitud heed Dron brother in
2013 scientists discovered that amplitud
he
brother it's a genetic structure dude
and it exists outside of space and time
brother which means space and time might
not exist at all dude they could be
emergent properties of an actual reality
made of Consciousness
man and that's amplitud hedron dude an
amplitud hedron dude trampled the region
mother handled the Dune renewed amplitud
hedron brother amplitud hedron dude
sampled the season
[Applause]
blubber dismantled the beacon dude
amplitud hedron brother amplitud hedron
dude and that's science brother he got
one thing wrong in there what's that
it's a geometric
structure all right
uh well let me tell you something about
corpses man they found decaying corpses
improperly stored in a funeral in
Oklahoma brother what I guess the owner
of the place the owners of the place
were charged with 200 counts of abusing
a corpse dude you can't abuse a corpse
brother not in the state of Oklahoma
dude Oklahoma cares about they corpses
brother they treat him with respect dude
they give him all certificates to
Starbucks brother and then they let him
run for public office dude and then they
give him F fashion Awards brother what
the is going on here best dressed corpse
dude best corpse hat brother best corpse
Ensemble dude best corpse Couture
brother best corpse collection dude best
corpse designer
brother and that's corpses dude that one
made sense yep well let me tell you
something about memorabilia brother
Winston Churchill's false teeth are
going to be auction dude is that true
that's gross that could be true that
sounds like it could be true yeah I
think uh they think hold on dude hold on
hold on dud hold on Chad they think
they're going to get $10,000 for those
dir Chompers
man he's bit a lot of famous people with
those teeth brother
what church WIll bit Gandhi dude church
WIll bit chaplain brother trip church
WIll bit molini dude church WIll bit
Stalin brother church WIll bit Picasso
dude Church bit airart brother Churchill
bit trosky dude Churchill bit kiping
brother and that's teeth dude holy [__]
all right he bet AIA moving on I didn't
know that yeah that's I knew about
Gandhi I knew about that was a very
famous incident where he bit Gandhi he
bit Gandhi I don't think so no I don't
think so either I don't think he bit
people no weird a new study was
published this week detailing a new
cloning technique that has allowed a
team in China to successfully clone
primates at present only two species of
monkeys have been cloned but this
technology will eventually allow for the
cloning of human beings will and Chad
I'm very curious to hear what you both
think about the idea of cloning human
beings don't hold back this is clone
heads begin uh bad idea good idea um
look what yeah all right first of all
let me just ask you this did you ever
see a movie called The Island by I
believe brookheimer directed It
brookheimer produced it nope or maybe
Michael Bay directed it one of those two
things is true maybe both it is one of
my most enraged moments at movie
trailers in the trailer they show the
final shot of the movie which is the
culmination of the plot [__] livid
but that movie was about clones it was
about uh rich people who had all kinds
of like diseases and [__] or whatever
they would clone themselves they stored
the Clones in this weird facility then
they would kill the Clone and harvest it
for organs to put into the real person
and then the Clones get wise to it and
they're like we got to [__] break out
of here yeah dude that's what the
Chinese government is doing dude they're
trying they're selling organs on the
black market dude high is bitter brother
oil billionaires dude buying Chinese
organs dude that's possible that's
what's happening why do you think it's a
bad idea to clone humans because because
you know what I'm going to say and all
of all of our pods palad dudes out there
know that I've well whatever I believe
I've had just about enough of making new
things out of old people unless we're
talking about my Arnold I mean my Arnold
hold on dude that's a different well
hold on dude that's a different imp
impersonation brother today it's Hulk
Hogan uh no I'm just kind of like who
cares we don't need it it's it's twins
[__] what you against twins who's making
the twins who yeah people I'll tell you
who's making the twins brother God up on
high dude only those are the only people
dude that's the only people you could be
twins dude but not like that those
Killer Bees brother Jumping Jim
brunzelle and B Brian Blair dude they
put those B masks on you couldn't tell
them apart even though Jumping Jim
brunzel had a bit of a a thicker body
dude but I don't want to get started on
that brother yeah dude let's talk about
bodies dude um okay so you're against
what the human intervention in the
process of creating human life 100% it's
useless what IVF or test tube
babies well what okay what do you mean
specifically about test Tu saying where
do you draw the line in terms of like
you're against human cloning but we can
use human intervention to help women get
pregnant to uh grow a baby in a Petri
dish and then put it in a surrogate yeah
okay that's all fine yeah of course
that's fine the line for you is cloning
specifically the line for me is a human
soul Chad and uh uh you you might want
to put your Sith Lord hood back on for
this because because the the point is uh
a baby that is needs a Little Help from
our you know the wonderful advancements
that humankind has made from Medicine
sure let's help that baby out there's
already a soul there you know what I'm
saying what if through cloning
technology you could make something that
is let's just say a giant amorphous
organic blob that just grows organs for
us to use to harvest and yeah that's
fine it's like the cloning that's
cloning like the lab meat thing I'm
talking about cloning a human being okay
all this is heading towards cloning a
human being I'm out no need to do that
the we got lots of human beings dude we
got lots of human beings in the Royal
Rumble coming up brother we got 30
gigantic musclebound human beings dude
that are going to get launched over that
top rope okay I'll I'll take this
conversation where you're taking it what
if they could clone Andre the Giant and
bring him back
now you're
no no I am not what the [__] you would
want to see a new Andre the [__]
giant cloned wrestling Roman Reigns
right now no I don't no no there's only
one there's only one Andre the Giant
there's only one Mar H Hulk Hogan to the
contrary I think it would be
disrespectful to bring back Andre the
Giant look I'm all for stem cell
research I'm all for uh all everything
with regard to helping human beings that
are alive H but you know it's a very
it's an ethical line that I don't think
we should cross because when you start a
a human a human body what embodies the
body and I'm not talking about that
dirty Jesse The Body Ventura dude wining
that Jesse The Body ventur award brother
let me tell you something Rick Rude when
you won the Jesse The Body award that
was cool dude when I saw you get up in
front of all my hulkamaniacs and strip
down to your skip dude I made up my mind
there brother I'm going to snap your
arms and legs in the middle of the Ring
dude as an actual promo I um sorry what
was the
question what do you think of the
possibility of human cloning that is now
these Chinese scientists have have
cloned these two different kinds of
monkey species and the monkeys have
lived multiple years I think one has
lived like three years it's the longest
any primate has has lived so they
essentially are getting closer and
closer to uh perfecting cloning
technology where it can be used on
primates AKA us and I think eventually
that that science it will get to a point
where somebody is going to do it some
government is going to do it some
private lab is going to do it and it
will be a big outrage and there will be
a conversation uh kind of in the public
Town Square about should this be allowed
or not but it won't matter it will have
already been done um there will be a
first cloned human being I think the
benefits to uh getting to the end of
this technology and that seems like it
is the the kind of Pinnacle of it I
think those far outweigh whatever kind
of detrimental ethical questions we may
have about it you know what are you
going to do and what you going to do
when uh you know when you act we don't
need the what do you mean what do we
need human beings to clone for we don't
know what the [__] I mean they are just
going to
be they're going to be it's going to be
I I don't want to see it I mean it's
going to be disgusting it's going to be
disgusting you already see it twins are
this no they are not they are they are
clones of one another they're not the
same Soul
CH the soul issue the soul issue okay so
then you're right they're not the same
Soul I'll give you that yeah neither
would the Clone have the same Soul as
the person it's cloned from it's just
like twins they have two different Souls
you don't know where the [__] souls
are coming from or going and that's a
problem with science I mean so that's
well that's the problem with science
dude the Hulk the hulster doesn't have
any problems with science dude I did all
my studies in school brother but uh no
you can't you can't I I like the The
Matrix blob you're you're describing
that spits out arms and legs and kidneys
for people that's totally fine that
thing doesn't have a soul what if it has
a
brain don't give it a brain it's going
to have to have one to live to keep the
functionality of that biological mass in
motion no it's not that hook that [__]
up to all your gutty works and stuff
outside of the [__] brain to me what
a soul not about the brain it's a soul
for you a soul to me I think we we view
it differently slightly for me it's
about Consciousness and I do believe
each of us have a a different um entry
point to kind of a universal
Consciousness or whatever call that a
soul if you want call it a personality
Call It Whatever I think if you clone a
human being that new clone gets a new
Soul Consciousness whatever you want to
call it it just it just sucks one out of
the universe and says come on down cuz
here's what I think's going to happen
you're going to let's let's say we reach
This creepy eventuality and there's um
and there's a a person you know who's uh
born or whatever they're going to aside
from other unforeseen health issues and
all sorts of wacky [__] cuz they're not
going to be able to get this right um
there's going to be a child and that
child's going to get to you know 5 years
old 10 years old 20 years old and go
what the [__] am I where did I come from
why the [__] did you people do this or
it might human on planet Earth gets to
that point or it might just be
blubbering uh nothing and just
going because sure because because
there's no soul in there right but the
theoretical question is eventually they
can perfect the science but perfect the
science of Souls of cloning Soul science
dude well I mean that we we talked about
this one time on this very show I think
you called it a soul line or something
like what animals have souls and which
ones don't and all that kind of [__]
they've successfully cloned a bunch of
different kinds of animals mhm do those
have
souls no these monkeys don't no I don't
think so did the the original monkey
that they cloned it from have a soul
yeah so you think clones can't have
souls uh I that's what I believe yeah
but twins can twins are not clones they
are genetic clones they're made
identical twins are for they're coming
from a human being just as our maker
intended okay so if you could clone
something and have it come out of a
human being you'd be fine with it no
that's a twin no it's it if we if you if
if H if you are starting the conception
you know what I mean I think that you
are
you're playing God and you're bringing
something into the world uh for which
there is no pre-ordained and I'm not
getting religious I'm just talking I'm
talking about science sure well I'm
talking about science dude kind of I
mean a soul is not science but well
that's soul science dude and that's
something I've talked about right here
on this very program dude you don't know
what's going to happen when you get you
it could go actually hold on you're a
soul scientist get well here's the thing
dude you might if you if you start a
soul dude you might have that Soul be a
perfect Soul dude just like Hulkamania
dude you got that perfect Soul who's
doing the training saying the prayers
eating the vitamins following the
demandments of Hulkamania brother and
that's a soul for good dude but then you
might also encounter The Evil Soul dude
and we're talking about that NWO brother
we're talking about that that person who
knows where the power lies who says NWO
for Life Dude too sweet and my my point
is that no you have no way of predicting
uh what's going to come out and I think
it's a horrifying Prospect and I think
we should just leave it alone and not do
that stem cells great you know shoot
them into your shoulder and your [__]
knee go down to South America and do it
on the cheap if you like about this and
RIS getting what theoretical situation
we allow human cloning uh by various
governments and scientific organizations
for let's say a time span of two years
and everything that is made through
these processes must be destroyed
whatever but we get a bunch of
scientific data out of that and it
allows us to cure all genetic diseases
would that be worth it to you all of
that's worth it I'm just saying we can't
have people walking around like Vincent
and arrio in uh Men In Black mhm you're
going I mean it's just going to be [__]
they're just going to be zombies kill me
you ever see that movie Moon kill me no
what's that uh it's Sam Rockwell movie
where he is a guy trapped or not trapped
he runs this little like base on the
moon all by himself he has a little
robot Helper but he like goes out he
mines The Ore he brings it back and he's
uh having these video conversations with
his family back on Earth or so he thinks
he comes to find out he is a clone in a
long series of clones at that go like
wonky at a certain age and then they
just replace it with a new one and the
videos he's watching are uh they show
the same videos to every clone that
comes through there and that's a movie
dude but that's not what would happen
that's not what would happen well that
was very dystopian you don't want that
to happen the Clones were
trapped it all that I don't [__] know
what you're talking about m m night
shamalan I'm telling you this it was M
Night sham you can't it wasn't M Night
Shyamalan let me tell you something I've
never figured out a [__] M Night
Shyamalan movie dude those things make
no [__] sense dude but I'll tell you
what makes sense brother the training
the saying your prayers the eating your
vitamins dude and you can't say your
prayers dude if you can't talk and if
you're all gub gbed out like Vinnie
denafo in Men In Black
going then you almost did an Arnold
schwarzeneger there againe it didn't
start go but you then you can't you
can't say your prayers dude and those
old vitamins are going to be shooting up
your ass via your little Matrix cubby
with you're sitting in that blue gel and
uh was the last thing training dude you
could definitely do some training
they'll be hooking you up to all sorts
of machines seeing what you're capable
of before the Chinese government Cuts
your limbs off dude and sells him to the
highest bidder on the black market
brother what about a chimera huh uh a
mixture let's say you could mix Hulk
Hogan and Andre the Giant into one new
wrestler would you that all of these
things no no to all of these things
there's only one Hulk Hogan there's only
one Andre the what I'm into it I would
love to see oh we know you're into it we
know you're into all that crazy stuff
Sith Chad
yeah thank you moving
on sure
sick hey everyone I just wanted to pop
in and remind you to check out dudy
store.com our stock is in stock and our
inventory is in inventory we're talking
the largest variety of dudy shirts in
the tri-state area dudy store.com is
your source for the dudy mug office
Olympics this year and we both know your
mother has been begging you to come over
and fix those hallway light bulbs well
you better not show up without a good
job boner mug or she'll cry and you'll
be responsible for her unending sorrow
change the light bulbs and bring her a
godamn mug she brought you into this
Dying World now let's check in with the
Taffy tener spokesperson of the
decade oh my God what hey y'all this
ain't Miley Cyrus now if you've been
paying attention to my exploits you know
damn well I've been stuck in tener's
Tower for a hot minute well last week I
was looking for a way out and I went
down a hallway I never been down before
and y'all ain't going to believe this
[__] my goofy ass accidentally fell into
a dimensional Schism and wound up
trapped in the 15th goddamn Dimension
y'all it was wild they had DMT space
elves in cop outfits they had dark
matter hamburgers they had ampl to
hedron [__] they had human
consciousness flavored t chips what else
do they have I don't know who cares I'm
still stuck in [__] tener's tower
that Schism spit my witchy ass back out
right where I went in so looks like I'm
going to be here for a while longer let
everybody know I'm doing all right I'm
just bored as hell and I'm sick of
eating Taffy ERS for every goddamn
[Music]
meal
whoa not Miley Cyrus's back holy
[__]
the amplitud hedron is making a a good
showing in today's episode yeah dude
amplitud hedron dude and you know if
dudes he saying amplitud hedron dude
then that's what that's how you say
amplitud hedron dude yeah amplitud
hedron all right let's look at some uh
let's look at some let's read some
comments you know uh we appreciate
everybody out there hey subscribe to the
things go to dudy go to link tree.com
dudy and get all the stuff and follow
all of our stuff and thank you for
subscribing on you YouTube and uh or
your uh podcast platform of choice
please uh please uh you know interact
with these comments cuz as we know D is
always reading and listening as are we
this one is from these are from YouTube
from last week's episode this one's from
at Blue punk rocker who says oh man doy
has definitely kept its promise and
literally made each episode better than
the last that's nice uh the last five
episodes have been mindblowing I now
have 17 people in my basement watching
dudy on a 24-hour Loop and no one has
decided to leave they're all free to
leave any time but choose to say stay
wow what a testament to how amazing this
show is that's very nice yeah that is
and to the 17 people who are watching
this episode on a 24-hour Loop hats off
to you yeah hats off to you for sure
that's um Chad you have been talking
about oh [__] I got yellow mustache
makeup on my
lips okay uh hey you uh you've been
talking about how to get people to watch
dudy and stay watching dudy yeah 17
people in the basement that's good
that's a high number I would say that's
probably the most successful forced
watching strategy that we've heard of
yet yeah that's they're definitely
taking it to the extreme uh this is from
whist whale 8468 who said did Chad coin
a new phrase traditionally
alive I like that you said that I mean
you want to that's coining a new phrase
great it's a new phrase here's what
we're about to enter right now we are
in yeah going I say three [__]
sentences and you give me the eye roll
and lean back like that I got to sit
here and just get steamrolled by [__]
hul Hogan for an hour okay I'm I'm gonna
say this it's important we're entering
this this new era where traditionally
alive is going to be a thing I think
we're going to have uh classic and
contemporary versions or classic and AI
versions of many artists actors
musicians we're just in a new time now
[__] has shifted and so yes
traditionally alive I think will refer
to when you are sitting here in your
biological Corpus the the degrading
thing moving toward entropy but I do
think um beyond that we will live
digitally all of us if you have data you
live forever okay this one here is
actually disgusting this is from at
zeron Edge x x no it's xiron Edge
x77 uh give Chad the belt will is drunk
with power and has become the heel
brother the cream Rises to the top and
Chad's as creamy as it gets
brother yeah I mean I have to agree with
that one and I think DS too by the looks
of this Hardware round me waist uh okay
last one at Mr jugal 909 been a while
since will spoke of his his love of
chips oh it has been a while actually
last week I talked about pizza flavored
chips yeah you did yeah because those
aren't [__] compared to a slice of New
York Pizza and I'm not going to get
going on the example I was making last
week just like clone I don't want cloned
chips would you eat human consciousness
chips like uh like not mly Cyrus had and
tapers yeah I would eat the the human
consciousness chips those I would eat
those I would eat will you do some
really fun Impressions impressions are
the best but there's one impression that
I personally think is the best of the
best and I want to help you make it even
better you're already dressed for it of
course I'm referring to your Hulk Hogan
impression what do you say will will you
trust me to make your Hulk Hogan better
if you trust me implicitly you'll find a
new impression optimization guide has
been sent to you this is impression
optimization 5 Hulk Hogan begin a Mania
yeah begin a
Mania you know what I'm realizing with
uh this being the the the 40-year
anniversary of Hulkamania being born oh
and by the way in dudy after dudy I
don't know if you're down with this Chad
but I would like to watch at least the
end of uh that match from 40 years ago
we're going to watch yeah let's do that
we're going to watch just you we're
going to watch part of the match Hulk
Hogan naric and the promos afterwards
Andre the Giant comes in that'll be a
good time but
as I was you know getting this goofy
outfit together uh for Goofy on me not
on Hulk cuz the red and yellow is
forever brother um I was thinking to
myself Hulk Hogan is the one
impression that I've been do I mean I've
been doing that for 40 years yeah and
now dudy wants to improve it in one
round of impression optimization yes
okay so that's not anyway that's not
exactly what's going to happen because
it's already just fine um but let's jump
into it anyway because when you're doing
doing an impression for 40 years and
again I'm not I don't stand by every
impression that I do but I think that's
a little ridiculous don't you that to
think that after 40 Years of doing an
impression I think every uh
performance-based thing that a human
being does can be
improved sure let's try
Okay uh this is
um this is s Hogan impression
optimization guide Baseline so I got to
say these things here to get it get it
tuned
up
five Z
7 Warrior wanted water when we worked
war games with William Regal wow all
right it's a tongue twister sital
awareness situational awareness please
do a brief improvisational monologue as
Hulk Hogan in the following
situations number one tasting a protein
bar and guessing the
flavor okay
oh hold on dude hold on Chad hold on
what is this this is oh it's got a
chocolatey flavor dude but it's not
chocolate chip cuz also tastes caramel
dude so that oh that must be salted
caramel hold on dude I'm GNA say I'm GNA
say butterscotch toffee Chocolate Crunch
uh with caramel dude that's pretty good
yep finding 200 pesos in his
pocket oh hold on oh dude I got a $20 no
I got oh wow dude 20 200 pesos brother
this must be from the last time that we
went to Mexico dude me and my lady
brother we had a good time down in PV
dude Port of Vara brother don't fall off
a scooter brother maybe I'll bring this
this note to the bank and get whatever
the exchange is right now dude10 to $15
or I'll just hang on to it dude leave it
in my Mexico pants and spend it the next
time I'm in Mexico
okay see you can't really improve on
that right it's really good uh reading a
thank you card from a friend who
received your wedding
gift
reading uh a thank you card uh oh hey
thanks thanks for the uh duve cover and
comforter set Terry he's using his real
name yeah uh we really appreciate it
dude it was awesome seeing you at the
wedding brother friends for life brother
thanks for coming to the wedding okay
all right all right fine-tuning phrase
ology please say well I don't know about
that dude in the tones described below
amused I don't know about that
dude
sad well I don't know about that dude oh
very
sad
oh I don't know about that dude
uh in response to someone saying that
Wonka wasn't a good
movie well I don't know about that dude
that's good one in response to being
dared to go down a creepy staircase into
a dark basement in a condemned
home I don't know about that
dude finding a dut in the toilet and
being tempted to eat it oh God have you
you ever done that no I've eaten nothing
from the toilet you've eaten nothing
from the toilet that's right have you e
even things that would be better if they
were a little wet you haven't eaten
anything out of a toilet look sometimes
all I'm saying is if you're living your
life right you're taking a piss and you
know you're having a sandwich or
something it falls in the toilet you
know but then you pick it up and it's
sort of that oou kind of thing you have
never eaten anything out of a toilet
you're not a piss Drinker you're not a
piss truther you you have never eaten
anything out of the to I've never eaten
anything out of the toilet
finding a donut in the tallet and being
tempted to eat it here it
goes oh I don't know about that dude see
he was tempted then he pulled off
scenarios yeah please oh this is
interesting please do your best Hulk
Hogan Scott Hall and Kevin Nash oh in
the following scenarios of course the
immortal Scott Hall rest in peace uh the
bad guy Razer Ramone and Kevin Nash Big
Daddy Cool Diesel big sexy uh uh Kevin
Nash I don't know that I have I love do
I always do my Scott Hall impression but
I hav uh Kevin Nash is kind of he just
kind of sounds like this he's big he's
he's you know he's big sexy he just kind
of sounds like this I watch him on uh
click this he has a podcast sure uh dudy
salutes big sexy Kevin Nash and he just
kind of gives his opinion on stuff he
didn't watch I watched the thing on him
he he did would not go and see uh
ironclaw he's like you a purist he's a
purist of course he's a he's a he's a a
wrestling uh Legend yeah so he has no he
has no intentions of seeing he's also
but ironclaw is a net positive because
ironclaw exists maybe there's going to
be a Prestige Oscar movie about him or
about the NWO at a certain point dude
let me tell you something let me tell
you this right now because this is where
the power lies and the
NWO is for Life dude put it
up um if there were a movie about the
NWO 100% I'm going to see that [__]
movie everybody is yeah oh you got that
right because it's running running it's
it's a new world order dude it's not the
new it's not the new some people order
dude it's the new world order so the
whole world's going to go see that movie
dude um uh if there was an NWO movie
that would knock me right off of my
Machine Gun Kelly as Kevin
Nash you know that some [__] like that
would
happen like at least we got the height
right no they didn't cuz Uh Kevin Nash
is damn near seven feet tall so uh let's
let's get into so CU Kevin Nash is just
kind of just talks like this you know
he's like hey you know I he's always
going like I never uh you know they'll
talk to him about different I I never
had a problem with uh I never had a
problem problem with Tully Blanchard man
you know I mean I was he was on his way
out when I was on my way in that's kind
of uh you got that one dial okay so uh
okay please do your best Hulk Scott Hall
Kevin Nash in the following scenarios
the three original members of the NWO
having a disagreement about
nachos oh hold on dude well listen every
time we we head over to chili dude
that's where they're getting their
nachos yeah dude we're riding together
cuz we're in the NWO dude and we get
them nachos brother and let me tell you
something dude Hall Scott you're always
uh getting the cheese and Kevin Na Nash
dude you're always reaching for the beef
dude trying to get that protein up after
you're after clanging and banging in the
gym
dude hey
yo I like cheese
and then Kevin that's and then Kevin I
don't [__] know this is
I'm hey I never had a problem with uh
you know eating just the chips but Hulk
I thought you were uh avoiding uh the
beef right now because I thought you
were doing the pescatarian thing but I I
never had a problem with I never had a
problem with beef nachos the the deal is
Chad yeah don't think this can be I
don't think that this impression can be
improved and I mean Hulk Hogan
specifically your Hulk Hogan you mean
yeah I mean look you you have your
attitude about it like you said you've
been doing it for 40 years obviously you
would know but everything can always be
improved the three original members of
the NWO laughing about seeing Ric Flair
fart in Diamond Dallas Page's face while
he's asleep on a plane of course did
that really happen no uh that well
probably I don't [__] know all sorts
of things happen when wrestlers get
together and get on planes there's um a
lot of wrestling fans know about the
plane ride from Hell which was a WWE
plane ride I guess this is a WCW thing
uh if this ever happened with this group
of guys all together in the uh although
you know in the early 2000s in the WWE
you had the NWO in there you had Diamond
Dallas Page in there and you also had
Ric Flair uh okay I'm going to bore I'm
I don't want to bore our non
uh wrestling uh fans out there okay so
this is the three original members of
the NWO laughing
about hold on dude that was amazing
brother you saw Ric Flair get up uh on
that chair on that chair dude with his
feet on either of the armrest brother
and he pulled his pants down just a
little bit dude he already ready oh he
farted right in Ric Flair's face dude
hey yo a d didn't even wake up you know
do must be smelling his upper
lip uh he didn't he slept right through
that fart I never had a problem with
with Flare farting in my face especially
while I'm flying on a plane anything to
break up the monotony okay the three
original members of the NWO talking
about Carrie Von Eric's body
oh Carrie von Eric was built like a
Greek god dude he had those pecs sitting
up on high and bowling ball shoulders
brother but maybe the most impressive
part of his body dude were his legs dude
he had big thick thighs hey
yo hey hul quit being a mark for
Carrie's thighs brother he had big yeah
he had he had big he had big thighs but
uh me and big Kev were talking about in
the back and uh we just want to let you
know we don't care hey
yo I never had a problem with Hulk
liking uh yeah kri Von Eric's thighs man
I mean I like Carri Von Eric's krie von
Eric had a great body I never had a
problem with it all right scene workor
last one please read this iconic
monologue [__] hell please read this
iconic monologue from Aaron Brockovich
oh my God in Aaron Brockovich as Hulk
Hogan
okay hold on yeah this is the scene when
she's giving everyone [__] in that
boardroom yeah um this is what won her
the Oscar yep Aaron Brockovich this this
speech I think was like this was it
that's a good point um oh it's oh okay
uh I gotta tell you I mean I just I
don't want to I never want to go against
what D all right
anyway give it your all this is the
least um bring some drama win an Oscar
right here win Hulk Hogan an osar this
is the least um necessary
um episode of Chad we're having a good
show
okay yeah I know all right let's just
let's just let's finish strong even
though we don't need to improve that's
all I do the Hulk Hogan uh
impersonation Oh see now that pisses me
off first of all since the demur we now
have more than 400 plaintiffs let's be
honest we all know there's more out
there now they may not be the most
sophisticated people but they do know
how to divide and $20 million isn't [__]
when it's split between them and second
of all these people don't dream about
being rich they dream about being able
to watch their kids swim in a pool
without worrying they'll have to have a
hysterctomy at age 20 like Rosa Diaz a
client of ours or have their spot
deteriorate like Stan Bloom another
client of ours so before you come back
here with another lame ass offer I want
you to think real hard about what your
spy is worth Mr Buddha or what you'd
expect someone to pay for your uterus
Miss
Sanchez then you take out your
calculator and multiply that number by a
100 anything less is a waste of our time
by the way we had that water brought in
special for you folks came from a well
in
Hinkley dude that was beautiful thank
you very well done moving on thank you D
for what it's
worth guys we've done a few of these but
every time we do it I get so much
incredible data so we're doing it again
that's right another standard
psychological evaluation just sit back
and relax I'll show you some images and
I want you to tell me the first thing
that comes to your mind just let
yourselves go this is a standard
psychological evaluation begin all right
standard psychological
evaluation uh always interesting when
dudy does this and uh you know this is
I'm very [__] confused today uh
because dud is throwing all sorts of
weird [__] at us I sort of feel like um
you know
we Chad gross we um it was me everybody
uh you're on video doing it yeah I know
I know it's a dumb bit I know I admit
I'm just ready to peel the onion today
I'll tell you that you know I'm just a
little confused because D's got me
dressed up like uh the hulkster Hulk
Hogan and uh it's got me [__] doing
the impression in a very weird way and
uh you got the [__] belt and all
sorts of other shits going on but uh
anyway what are you going to do about it
oh okay and first thing that comes into
mind uh for me the first thing that
comes to mind is Lim biscuit guitarist
Wes Borland West Borland for me as well
yeah because we are looking at a picture
of West Borland yeah in one of his many
looks uh uh he's got a he's got some
interesting face paint on he's got a a a
very very interesting he's wearing a
very interesting jacket and uh West
Borland and he's got some kind of
technological device around his neck um
I saw LMP biscuit live open for Faith No
More in what must have been 1998 I
believe nice nice before they were big
before the whole new metal thing had
really started to take hold like it did
and I remember uh West Brin walked out
on the stage Durst had the the Red Cap
and there was this guy that was a guitar
player who had this thing that was
basically like a leather like patch
around his face with a carrot nose
sticking off of it and two like
rectangular slits for eyes and I was
just mesmerized I was like what in the
[__] is this guy yeah West Borland is
[__] great man actually I dig I dig
the thing about you know like when one
person in the band is doing something
completely [__] different West
Borland takes it to the
extreme it's just one of those days you
don't want to that's pretty good thanks
man actually well that's an impression I
used to do on Mad TV dude was uh was oh
lulio is up and oh okay here's another
uh picture thing that pops in your mind
uh West Borland West Borland for me as
well in this one it looks like he has
some layers of denim that have been
bunched into a uh some sort of a pant
his body is painted completely uh looks
like uh gray kind of just a hippopotamus
uh you know automobile gray and then he
has a one golden shoulder and his face
is just sort of a a a you know a
nondescript sort of just covering on his
face with two holes um you know I did a
project with Fred dur oh that's right
for Showtime many years ago a pilot that
that wound up going nowhere but in it he
was going to play a version of himself
and many of the real friends that he has
in real life were going to be in it like
Mark McGrath was going to play his best
friend in the show who's also his best
friend and West Borland was supposed to
be in it as well and uh I was told that
West Borland now spends most of his time
in his house I believe in Orange County
if I remember right making swords in his
garage that he has turned into a
blacksmith shop [__] well he's
certainly an artistic guy so that that's
really cool I you know I used to do that
impression of Fred Durst on Mad TV and
actually I'll tell you something
interesting uh we the when we used to do
that my our good friend Cyrus the Jesse
Pinkman of she legit Health would always
portray uh West Borland W when we did
that sketch he looks like him dude that
is he does look like him and when we did
the you know after doing the sketch and
[__] then I I remember meeting Fred
Durst he goes he goes I don't really do
I really talk like that or whatever when
we're talking he goes I've never said
holy macaroni and I said yeah you
actually did you said holy macaroni one
time on an MTV show where they were U
the new album was coming out and they
had like an MTV special which by the way
that might be why dudy has us watching
this there's been a lot of
MTV stuff now we've barely talked about
Hulkamania but MTV had a hand in
Hulkamania did it really yes as a matter
of fact did it do well
MTV aired the original um War to settle
the score and brawl to settle it all
yeah yeah uh with um Cindy ler came into
the mix and that's when um Rody Piper
body slammed her manager or whatever her
partner there and uh we just watched the
1984 Video Music Awards uh which was 40
years ago so it there's I I'm not
exactly sure why dudes he has us doing
oh okay and here's another picture what
comes to mind when you see
this I mean it West Borland isn't the
first thing that comes to mind it is
underwear I think yeah West Borland in
this one is wearing he's got his outfit
in this one is his mouth is sort of
painted like a black and white butthole
and he's got some uh red blades on he's
got a shiny sort of looks like um like
some sort of
Victorian uh jacket or something
Liberace would wear Liberace was at the
first WrestleMania was he really yes he
was see this is all coming together just
as a fan in playing the piano oh yeah
everyone was there uh Muhammad Ali was
there really uh New York Yankees manager
Billy Martin wow yeah it was a big it
was a big to-do and in this one uh it
looks like uh he's got well his thighs
are out and he's drawn pentagrams on his
knees he's got pentagrams on his knees
and he's got some thick thighs dude
maybe not as thick as Carrie von Eric
brother but uh I don't know why the [__]
we're talking about any this Today's
Show is a mind [__] it's been a weird
one thank you moving on West
Borland all right God now I'm thinking
about faith 89 feels so fine I had a
great time with you boys today and you
scored 92 total points now you have
8,355 overall points you're only
1,645 points away from the grand reveal
that will happen at 10,000 you know what
this coming weekend is it's the 2024
Royal Rumble emanating live from
Tropicana Field in St Petersburg Florida
I'd like for both my darling Pals to get
together as dear friends and watch it
then register your thoughts here next
week I'm particularly looking forward to
hearing the reaction from Pro
wrestling's newest fan our very own
Champion handsome Chad colen oh I can't
wait to render that reaction you know
the only Royal Rumble I've seen is the
Ric Flair one that dudy also had us
watchat that's awesome okay cool uh at
the end of a very odd show we're we're
staying we're staying thick with the
themes there's a lot of themes happening
lately here uh on dudy as D works his
mysterious ways that's going to be fun
next Saturday uh the it's the the 27th
or 2th or whatever it's the Royal Rumble
and uh okay let's watch it you're going
to have to come over sure and watch the
Royal Rumble and I'll dress like this
thanks to everyone who joined us this
week I already know the data I got today
is going to make next week even better
until then call me
dudy
Dy yeah
hold on
dude dudy after dudy is where the power
lies dude and it's a dudy after dudy
time it's our favorite time after the
show when it's dudy after dudy yeah look
at handsome Chad he's got his [__]
belt and uh oh what a wing nut of a show
this was I tell you what things are a
little more chilled out we're probably
going to get into the gabis not just cuz
we're clanging and banging in the gym
dude uh but because it's what we do dudy
after dudy so I hope you are going to
stay and join us patreon.com dudy and
we'll get right into it you know welcome
to dudy after dudy the flagship weekly
show of dudy Plus available only at
patreon.com dudy you guys turned in
another solid performance today but
winning the belt's not just about today
is it there are other factors to
consider for example what you did last
week might also be relevant to today's
score just keep that in mind will this
is D after dudy get it okay all right I
don't know what the [__] that someone's
been having some fun with you well
that's definitely Robert loia brother
it's a coach for Major League it's a
heart attack hey um it's the 40th
anniversary of
Hulkamania uh it's unbelievable to think
that it's been 40 years and I got to say
this is not the first time and won't be
the last that I dress as Hulk Hogan in
my lifetime
um uh Chad would you like to see uh some
footage of me dressed as Hulk Hogan 10
years ago on Monday Night Raw getting
choke slammed by Kane uh yes I would
love to see that footage thank you dudie
can we can we do you have that can we
look at
that if you like d here's what you
do
please tell a friend then
bre if you like d here what
you please tell a friend then